I gave it a prompt asking what should
Harvard's strategy in online education
be
in a way that preserves the magic of the
campus experience and you know it typed
out a fine essay but it was pretty
generic
I then current based the essay and gave
it back to chat GPD and I said if this
was the answer to an essay prompt like
this how would you grade it
and it said I would give it a grade of C
plus because it's not Harvard specific
enough which was absolutely fascinating
because I was like actually this is not
just for giving answers it's for grading
answers and there's a certain degree of
self-awareness or Dare essay humidity
here